كما تظاهر اردنيون في منطقه مجمع الاغوار
شمال الاردن وذلك على بعد بضعه كيلومترات
من المعبر الشمالي الرابط بين المملكه
واسرائيل المتظاهرون الذين لبوا دعوه
المعارضه الاسلاميه دعوا الى تدشين جسر
مساعدات بري لقطاع
غزه معنا من مجمع الاغوار شمال الاردن
مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي تامر ماذا عن
هذه المظاهره ورمزيه المكان مجمع الاغوار
رمزيه مهمه في الحقيقه عبد القادر هذه
تظاهره كان يفترض ان تصل الى المعبر
الشمالي الرابط بين المملكه الاردنيه
والاراضي المحتله لكن هنالك قرار من
السلطات الاردنيه منذ بدء العدوان او
الحرب على قطاع غزه الحرب
الاسرائيليه بعدم يعني تنظيم اي احتشادات
او احتجاجات عند النقاط الحدود و هذه اخر
نه استطاع المتظاهرون الوصول اليها نحاول
ان نقرب لكم الصوره بشكل اوضح وهي منطقه
تبعد بضعه كيلومترات عن المعبر الشمالي
الرابط كما قلت بين المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه والاراضي المحتله
والمطالبات هنا تركز بشكل اساسي على ان
يكون هذا المعبر ونتحدث عن ثلاث معابر في
الحقيقه تربط
بالاراضي المحتله بان يكون هذا المعبر
يعني جسرا بريا لغزه من اجل يعني انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه من اجل ايصال المساعدات
للمحاصرين الفلسطينيين الذين يقبعون تحت
هذه الحرب التي لا ترحم كما يقولون وايضا
يطالبون الحكومه الاردنيه بموقف اكثر
صرامه من مما يجري في القطاع من العدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه ولذلك المطالبات
ايضا تتركز على ضروره قطع العلاقات
الاردنيه الاسرائيليه الحديث هنا عن
اتفاقيه السلام
الاردنيه مع اسرائيل وهي اتفاقيه وادي
عربه الموقعه منذ العام 944 والتي ينظر
اليها شعبيا هنا بعين العداء وايضا
المطالبه باغلاق السفاره الاسرائيليه في
عمان و يعني ان لا يكون هنالك ك اي علاقات
بين عمان وتل ابيب للتذكير عبد القادر
الحكومه الاردنيه كانت استدعت السفير
الاردني من تلبيب في نوفمبر الماضي وذلك
احتجاجا على الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه واتخذت كما قالت جمله من الخطوات لا
سما المتعلقه منها بتجميد التوقيع على
اتفاقيه تتعلق بالماء بين البلدين ولكن
المطالبات هنا كما في عديد المحافظات
الاردنيه تركز وتطالب تكون المواقف
الرسميه اكثر يعني تفاعلا واكثر حده في
ضوء استمرار اسرائيل بهذه الحرب التي
تشنها على قطاع غزه المحاصره شكرا لك تامر
الصمادي كنت معنا من مجمع الاغوار شمال
الاردن